Brent Musburger was honored a couple of
nights ago and he got the Lifetime
Achievement Sports Emmy and told some
great stories he's the lead voice
play-by-play announcer of Vegas stats
and information network on Sirius XM
Brent good morning how are you good
Marty dan I am uh I'm great what was the
poor question what was the what was the
question you guys throughout today
McClure we asked was there cheater
overrated correctly rated or underrated
everybody said correctly rated what was
the majority as a hurricane yeah yeah
joy you go with the majority yeah uh I
was wondering about you weren't
emotional when you got this Lifetime
Achievement Award you were having fun
telling stories were you surprised that
like you weren't emotional you know I
never expected to be emotional you know
looks at them but I trap hold on second
Brent we're going to get a better phone
line there yeah you want to take a break
and then we'll come back we'll see you
can get Brent on a better line for sure
we'll do that you weren't emotional you
were just telling stories that's where
we left off how come you weren't
emotional and kind of reminiscing there
you know Dan I never expected to be
emotional because I've had such a great
journey and you can't be fun at the old
ballpark my friend you know this is
there's a lot of things in this world
they're a lot more serious but going to
sporting events and I listen I've
enjoyed my life every minute other came
away with great memories great
friendships and no I never I never
thought it was going to be emotional
tell you the truth you do tell some fun
stories though now can we tell the story
about the the steam room in the sauna in
Europe when you you showed up naked
it's it I get a days up today I should
have told the the end game on it too
because as you know I had drew as a cop
the Emmy award-winning director of
Sunday Night Football who had worked a
lot of football with me back in the day
when I came over to ABC and so he and I
was doing the World League of American
football in places like Barcelona and
Frankfurt and we were in a hotel in
Frankfurt Germany and we were at full
side it was mid morning we gained that
night and and he said to be true said to
me you know I think I'm gonna go down
and take a sauna and I said actually I
wish I could do that I don't I don't
have my swimsuit with me and he said but
but this is Europe this is Europe my
friend
nobody wears a swimsuit inside a sauna
it was okay I'll see you down down Golf
is just cup of coffee I'll be down
so drew proceeded to go down stairs and
put on his swimsuit as he told the crowd
theater died and of course I went
walking down and there were hangers
there to put your clothes and so I got
undressed went over to the sauna opened
the door and there must have been four
or five people in there and then women
and they were all fully clad in her
swimsuit of course I was totally naked
as I opened the door and I said oh my I
couldn't wait I want to choke him like
this so I moved over to the corner of
the sauna as quickly as I could wait you
stated that naked oh yeah what do you
know Brent what if you would have said
you are looking live that would have
been the best thing to say but I was so
mad at him I wanted to just go check
he's up there with that - I heard the
Korean honors nice okay hang up on the
top rope now the kicker is I'm new going
to sit down wait till everybody got out
and then I would leave okay so everybody
left except except this one young Asian
woman who had the conch
tution of a marathon runner and who is
stretched out and just enjoyed this I am
sweating it is pouring off me all I want
to do but I do not want to walk out of
the palace finally gets up finally
leaves I hear the shower outside on that
I heard turned off
I finally leave finish shower good but I
can't wait to find him I just leave it I
wanted to drown him
round him some place and then to kick it
all off I was later know some small town
wasn't I was becoming a football game of
it meeting some people and we were at a
spa big big pool area in Germany and and
the sauna was upstairs and I said to my
friend who I couldn't work I second on I
didn't I didn't he said everybody wears
sauna suit when you go inside us are so
now we walked into that she perfectly
it's Charlotte and everybody was nude
except I haven't been able to get to you
you can't get it right but you go I just
um you also told a story when Doug
Flutie throws that touchdown pass that
helped him win a Heisman you were doing
the broadcast and Gerrard Phelan catches
the touchdown pass to win it against
Miami Jimmy Johnson's a head coach of
the Hurricanes but the aspect I didn't
know about this is the defensive
coordinator for Miami didn't see that
last play because he's coming down the
elevator and to beat the crowd so he's
not even there to be the defensive
coordinator for that final play that
helped Boston College win yeah exactly
they you know after Miami went in for
the go-ahead touchdown inside of a
minute to play he obviously thought that
the game was over and the one elevator
coming down from the old Orange Bowl and
it used to be a rush to get there these
days there's pretty much an attendant
there because the assistant coaches down
but he wanted to get out and so when
Boston College got a decent return and
put
fluted close to midfield and they lined
up for what would turn out to be the
winning touchdown there was a false
start and the Miami defense had come to
the line of scrimmage on that fall so
they were playing press coverage and
when the penalty was made Jimmy wanted
to get ahold of the defensive
coordinator and clarify exactly what
coverage they wanted to call or did he
want to substitute an extra wide
receiver or another defensive back into
the secondary
he couldn't get ahold of him because he
was in the he was in the elevator as it
turned out I you know needless to say
was he became the X because a
coordinated sort of Mexican so he wasn't
there when the wind uh grow the winning
touchdown passed down into the end zone
and and wasn't what's kind of
interesting about Gerrard failing at the
other end of it is I didn't have making
the cry didn't have any idea who had
caught it there were just so many bodies
down the end zone they tumbled down a
pile down that I just knew it was
somebody with Boston College Jersey on
but Kevin O'Malley one of our executives
at CBS was in the truck and he reached
over the producers shoulder pulled the
key back and said planet Phelan Gerrard
Phelan - which I never doubted it when I
heard Kevin's voice I knew he do because
he got to be saying so I called it by
the way and then Doug and I oh I don't
know three four years ago we did a piece
for Thanksgiving for ESPN for Sports
done about it and I related that little
story and Doug started to laugh and he
said you know Brent I didn't know who
caught it either he's I'm going up to
the locker room when I say to my Center
who caught the pass so the guy looks at
this as a Doug it's your roommate gerard
Phelan caught it so he was you know and
he just won the Heisman made that helped
him win the light him right it did and
you know what's interesting that is that
if you go back and it doesn't make any
difference what game it is and you go
back about 10 years or so and talk to
the participants
you're going to find stories like that
you will not find them immediately after
the game that's not going to happen
first of all does the emotion of the
moment
and second of all people are just aren't
going to tell you everything that went
on
Jimmy was not gonna Telemedia afterwards
that SOB was in the elevator and I
couldn't get a hold of him you know he's
gonna say listen we should have knocked
the ball down
congratulations to Doug Flutie and blah
blah blah blah the Google box but if you
go back if you go back about a decade
later hey that's why I love to sit
around and listen to athletes tell
stories of days gone by it's just
wonderful wonderful memories I think
really that's what I take away from is
all all the great memories and events
and moments and and the teamwork that
goes into it I mean when you doing radio
like basically is what we're doing it
Rison right now it's almost fall when
the screen gets up and gets going pretty
good and be sent on the Sirius XM it's
entirely it's entirely different you're
you're pretty much dependent on yourself
but when you get into a television
broadcast you've got so many people here
dependent upon I've had such great help
through the years who as I got just one
of many Hall of Fame directors I've I've
had a chance to work with sigh because I
come away with nothing but fondness and
and and great feelings for everybody in
the industry all the networks are great
shows that have put up you know I said
many a time that I love what you guys do
on Sunday night but before the sunday
nigh came in the studio I love the show
and the other day in DC at the Kentucky
Derby of course were all over pictures
that's you know one of the most bet well
it's the most that horse race out here
in Las Vegas and then I just loved with
the network's to and last night I
watched two game sevens when I got home
and Pittsburgh the Penguins moved on to
the Eastern Conference National Hockey
League playoffs at that Anaheim trailing
one nothing came back and and one with a
couple of goals and I was thoroughly
entertained I mean it the sports
business on television is just wonderful
and that's been really that's what I
take away from it wasn't it was about me
crying about being up there for 50 years
okay so bit John passed quickly I want
to ask you in the final two minutes how
does the NFL embrace betting
now it sits at that is such a good
question you know they have denied it
for a long long time I don't know if I
told you about the day one when she made
a great tonight when we put it first but
the Greek on the NFL today we went over
to Pete Rose ELLs office and we had a
meeting and I knew that Pete had
embraced gambling at the horse racing
level because I'd seen the racetrack
several times when he understood what
was going on and he just kind of asked
us not to put minus 3 plus 10 whatever
the numbers up there which we agreed to
and that's what led to the check board
the Greek and I used on the old days but
the truth of the matter is and people it
that the National Football League would
not be as big as it is today without
people enjoying wagering and it doesn't
have to always be points play gambling
you could you can play in pools where
you just pick winners every week and
millions of people do in this country
you take a chance but you love to have a
team whether it's $20,000 or just $20
you like to take a position now the big
change then and I was not sure that they
would do this I do the Raiders want to
come to Las Vegas but when the league
announces that the Raiders are coming to
Las Vegas it's game set match
okay there is no way now that they can
say that we do not accept it now whether
or not it ever becomes a standard
operating procedure for people other
than Al Michaels to say what over/under
numbers are and spread numbers I'm not
sure that they're quite there yet and
listen it's not the most important thing
it never will be the most but there's a
lot of money there in the NFL and money
making business absolutely and you know
when you go to Europe when you go to
Europe and you go inside the big soccer
stadium many of them you have
sponsorship agreements with Ladbrokes
and you know William Hill and all the
great bookmakers around the world so it
is going to eventually and it will be in
places in the United States beyond the
orders of nevada that's coming to okay
and the National Hockey League is coming
in here the NBA commissioner has talked
about it and we're talking billions of
dollars but every year and much of it
that offshore illegally with the
internet internet and the digital world
changed everything also so people to
better your keywords time and it's time
to have a regulated market for the
people to keep an eye on it see what's
going on and keep the money on shore in
the United States there's no reason for
it
I'd like to love that it I'd like to
dive into this when we have more time
just this topic itself I have some ideas
on it but um it was great to see you the
other night and I already talked to you
about it soon you got it thanks dad
Ives a lot hi buddy that's a Brent
Musburger now he told some great stories
going in the sauna you are looking live
at me naked and he didn't leave you know
the fact that he didn't leave that's the
great part of it the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience